♪ ♪
>> Tucker: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SPECIAL EDITION OF
"TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT."
THROUGHOUT THE LENGTH OF THIS
PANDEMIC, WE CHECKED IN
REGULARLY WITH DAVE PORTNOY DID
ABOUT HOW HE IS HOLDING UP
DURING THE LOCKDOWN.
RECENTLY HE HAD HIS OWN SCARE
WITH THE CORONAVIRUS.
HE JOINS US NOT TO DISCUSS HIS
TIME IN LOCKDOWN AND WHAT HE HAS
LEARNED.
I THANK YOU FOR JOINING US
TONIGHT.
SO, FIRST I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT THE EXPENDED PERIOD YOU
SPEND IN BED SICK.
DID YOU HAVE THE VIRUS?
>> YEAH, SO I DID.
I TESTED POSITIVE.
AS WE ARE FILMING THIS RIGHT
NOW, I JUST ENDED MY QUARANTINE
TWO DAYS AGO.
I WAS INSIDE FOR TWO STRAIGHT
WEEKS, 14 DAYS.
WHEN I MADE THE ORIGINAL VIDEO
SAYING I FELT SICK, I DIDN’T
KNOW I HAD IT.
I THINK I’VE HAD IT LIKE EIGHT
TIMES.
>> Tucker: WHERE DID YOU GET
IT?
YOU KNOW?
>> NO.
I WAS IN THE HAMPTONS AND I WAS
ACTUALLY WITH THE GROUP.
LIKE SIX OR SEVEN OF US ALL
TESTED POSITIVE.
WE WERE STAYING TOGETHER.
I WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHO GAVE IT
TO ME.
>> Tucker: YOU WERE STAYING
WITH SIX OR SEVEN PEOPLE AT ONCE
IN THE HAMPTONS.
I DON’T FEEL LIKE I SHOULD ASK A
FOLLOW-UP QUESTION THERE.
I AM GLAD YOU ARE OKAY.
>> IT’S A FIVE BEDROOM
APARTMENT.
IT WASN’T LIKE WE WERE ALL
CRAMMED TOGETHER.
>> Tucker: WHAT HAVE YOU
LEARNED FROM THE WHOLE
EXPERIENCE?
WE HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
VIRUS FOR MONTHS.
YOU ACTUALLY GOT IT.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN?
>> I DIDN’T LEARN ANYTHING
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT I THOUGHT.
I WAS VERY TIRED, EXHAUSTED FOR
TWO DAYS.
WITHIN THE GROUP OF US,
EVERYBODY WAS AFFECTED A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY.
BUT IT WAS A FLUKE.
IT WAS A COLD.
I WAS THE OLDEST OF THE GROUP.
WE HAD EVERYONE FROM MID 20s
TO MY AGE.
SOME PEOPLE GOT SICK.
SOME PEOPLE FELT BAD FOR A DAY.
I WAS SICK FOR TWO DAYS AND
EXHAUSTED FOR REALLY A WEEKEND
TO HAVE.
BUT THE BOTTOM LINE, YOU DON’T
HAVE UNDERLYING SYMPTOMS IF YOU
ARE NOT ALREADY ILL OR SUB SUB
SUSCEPTIBLE.
YOU ARE GOING TO GET OVER IT.
IT’S A REAL THING IF YOU ARE
ELDERLY OR YOU ARE HEALTH
IMPAIRED.
I THINK IT IS A REAL CONCERN.
BUT FOR 99% OF THE COUNTRY, IT
ACTS LIKE THE FLU.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
YOU SAY THIS FIRST HAND.
ONE OF THE REASONS I ADMIRE YOUR
RESPONSE TO THE LOCKDOWN EVEN
THOUGH YOU WERE SHOT OFF IN A
APARTMENT.
YOU ARE MEGA MOBILE THANKS TO
ONLINE TRADING.
HOW MUCH RICHER DID YOU GET
DURING THE CORONAVIRUS LOCKDOWN?
>> I DON’T LIKE TO TALK ABOUT
MONEY, BUT MY NET WORTH IS
PROBABLY, THE STOCK MARKET, I
WAS NEVER A STOCKMARKET GUIDE
GUIDE.
NEVER TRADED.
I ALWAYS LOOKED AT FINANCE GUYS
LIKE THEY WERE PULLING IT ON ME.
IT SEEMS TO GO UP LIKE 10%.
600 GRAND TODAY TRADING.
LITERALLY TODAY.
IT’S BEAUTIFUL.
I DON’T KNOW WHY ANYONE HAS A
JOB.
ALL YOU’VE GOT TO DO IS BUY
STOCKS AND WATCH THEM GO UP.
I DIDN’T KNOW THAT WOULD BE THE
CASE BUT IT HAS BEEN.
>> Tucker: BUT DOESN’T IT MAKE
YOU A LITTLE NERVOUS?
YOU ARE SITTING IN YOUR
APARTMENT.
YOU MAKE 600 GRAND.
AREN’T YOU TEMPTED TO CASH OUT
AND BUY A BIGGER PLACE?
>> YOU KNOW, I AM ALWAYS
TEMPTED.
BUT THE NATURE OF MY
PERSONALITY, I LIKE PUSHING
THINGS.
IF I WASN’T SOMEBODY WHO ALWAYS
WANTED TO BUILD MORE AND
ACCUMULATED MORE.
YOU DON’T GET MEGA YACHTS WITH
600 GRAND.
>> Tucker: [LAUGHS]
I ASKED YOU WHAT YOU HAVE
LEARNED.
YOU TAUGHT THE REST OF US HOW WE
SHOULD HAVE SPENT THE LAST FOUR
MONTHS.
>> WE ARE A CAPITALIST SOCIETY.
HOPEFULLY ONE DAY I CAN GET BACK